The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on Nonlinear Finite
Element Analysis of Solids and
Structures.
In the previous lectures, we
discussed quite general
kinematic formulations and
numerical algorithms that we
use for nonlinear finite
element analysis.
We also referred to and used a
stress strain matrix C, but we
did not discuss this matrix
in any depths.
This is the topic of
this lecture and
the following lectures.
The stress strain matrix C is
used in the calculation of the
K matrix, and is schematically
shown on this graph.
And of course, the stress strain
matrix is also used in
the evaluation of the force
vector F, as shown here.
The stress strain matrix, of
course, will be different for
different material behaviors.
It will be different for
different kinematic
formulations that we're using.
And all these aspects we now
have to discuss in this and
the following lectures.
We notice that when we do finite
element analysis, we
have the choice of different
kinds of formulations.
And we talked about the
formulation that takes only
into account infinitesimally
small displacements.
But of course, material
nonlinear behavior, we
actually call that formation
a materially nonlinear only
formation, an MNO formulation.
We may have or use a formulation
that takes into
account large displacements,
large rotations, but only
small strains.
This, for example, would be a
total Lagrangian formulation.
And we have also formulations
that take into account large
displacements, large locations,
and large strains.
And here we use, once again,
the total Lagrangian
formulation or an updated
Lagrangian formulation.
We discussed these formulations,
of course,
earlier in the earlier
lectures.
The applicability of material
descriptions is also very well
categorized in these
three categories.
In other words, there are
certain material description
constitutive relations that hold
for infinitesimally small
displacements and small strains,
and that are not
directly applicable
to large strains.
If, however, we have a material
description that is
applicable to infinitesimally
small displacements and small
strains, then we will see that
same material description can
directly be used also in the
large displacement, large
rotation, but small strain
analysis, provided we use the
proper formulation.
We will discuss this
aspect just now.
In fact, the formulation that we
are using in this category
of problems is a total
Lagrangian formulation.
Let us very briefly once more
recall that we have the
materially-nonlinear-only
formulation, as I just
mentioned, the total Lagrangian
formulation and the
updated Lagrangian formulation,
which we
discussed in earlier lectures.
And that really kinematically,
these formulations here
kinematically, for the analysis
of two dimensional,
three dimensional solids, using
isoparametric finite
element formations, we include
all large displacement, large
rotation, and large
strain effects.
Of course, whether the
formulation will actually be
applicable to model a particular
problem, will also
depends on whether we use and
have the right constitutive
relation for that problem.
And that is an aspect that we
will concentrate on now in
this and the following
lectures.
But notice that kinematically
these formations include all
nonlinearities.
If we look very briefly at
various material descriptions,
we have here typical models that
I used and examples of
applications, materials,
practically all materials
behave elastically as long as
the stress and the strains are
small enough.
A hyperelastic material
would be, for
example, a rubber material.
A hypoelastic material
would be the
concrete material model.
And elasto-plastic material
would be applicable to model
metals, soils, rocks under
high stresses.
A creep material model would be
applicable to model metals
at high temperatures.
When the temperatures are
high, then metals are
subjected very easily
to creep.
A viscoplastic material model
really takes into account the
elasto-plasticity and the
creeping effect of the
material and is used frequently
to idealize or to
represent polymers and metals.
We will talk about a number of
these material models in this
and the following lecture.
We will not go into depths of
concrete material models and
rock material models, but still
whatever we are talking
about is applicable to a wide
range of material models.
Let us first look now, in this
lecture, at the elastic
material behavior.
Elasticity means that for a
particular strain, you are
given a particular stress.
The history does not enter
in the solution.
And a linear elastic
stress strain
relationship is shown here.
Notice for the strain, tE, we
are given a stress t sigma.
And it's a unique stress.
It is a unique stress.
And of course, the history
of the formation does
not enter at all.
Notice that in this particular
case, we would have that
typically t sigma here is
equal to E times te.
te being of course this value
here, t sigma there.
Notice that an increment in
stress is given by d sigma
equal to E times de.
Linear elasticity, a linear
elastic material description,
means E is constant.
For nonlinear, as a nonlinear
elastic material description,
we might have schematically in
a one-dimensional analysis,
this relationship here,
the red curve.
Notice that, once again, for a
particular strain, we pick up
a unique value of stress.
And this relationship here
shows that t sigma is
given tC times te.
tC is the slope of
this line here.
Now, an increment in stress
is obtained by this
relationship here.
d sigma equals C times de.
Notice that C is not
the same as tC.
This is here, relating
the total stress
to the total strain.
Here we talk about an increment
in stress related to
an increment in strain.
It's important to note that
C is not the same as tC.
Unless, of course, we have a
linear elastic relationship.
In a computer program, we would
represent such a curve
typically by a series of
straight lines, as shown here.
And the input, of course, would
be these points here,
and the corresponding points
on the stress curve.
Notice that if you take a large
number of such straight
segments, you can really
approximate a continuous curve
such as this one here
quite well.
We can generalize this elastic
material behavior using the
total Lagrangian formulation,
as shown here.
Notice that the total stress,
second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress-- we talked about
this stress measure
in an earlier lecture--
is given by the stress strain
law times the total strain.
Green-Lagrange strain-- once
again we talked about this
strain measure in an
earlier lecture.
Incrementally, we have
this relationship.
The increment in the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress is
related to the increment in the
Green-Lagrange strain via
this constitutive law.
Notice that this tensor or the
components of this tensor are
not the same as those components
in general.
This material description is
frequently employed in two
types of analysis, the usual
constant material moduli for
infinitesimal displacement
analysis.
Or for rubber-type analysis,
rubber-type materials, I
should say, where of course this
matrix is not constant.
And that matrix is not
constant either.
I like to now spend
time on discussing
these type of analyses.
The use of the constant material
moduli means, for
example, for an isotropic
material, that we use these
matrices given via this
relationship here.
Notice lambda and mu are the
Lame constants, that you're
probably familiar with, and data
ij is the Kronecker data,
defined as shown down here.
These are the same constants
that are used
also in linear analysis.
So no new parameters are
introduced here.
As examples, here we have the
stress strain law for the 2-D
plane stress analysis.
I've written it in matrix form,
and this zero here means
total Lagrangian formulation.
And notice that there could
also be a t up here.
In other words, we use the same
matrix for the increment
in the stresses and for
the total stresses.
So I could very easily put a t
up there, and we notice then
that the last row corresponds
to this relationship here.
It's important to recognize that
on the right hand side
here, we have the Green-Lagrange
strain, t0 zero
epsilon 12 plus t0 21.
In other words, we take the
total sharing strain into
account here.
And that gives us then
this row and
that column, of course.
For 2-D, access symmetric
analysis, we would use this
stress-strain law, once again,
for the increments in the
stresses and for the
total stresses.
For an orthotropic material, we
would typically have this
stress strain law in plane
stress, plane strain analysis.
And there you see
again, the zero.
Notice Ea, Eb are the material
and nu ab are the material
moduli corresponding to the
a and b, directions and
similarly the sheer
modulis Gab.
The material being orthotropic
means Ea is not equal to Eb.
This once again is the material
law that we are quite
familiar with from
linear analysis.
Now let's look at the sample
problem, the sample analysis.
And I would like to choose a
very simple problem to just
demonstrate some of the aspects
of using a total
Lagrangian formulation with
a constant material law.
Here we have a bar, with cross
sectional area A bar.
We use the material constants E
and nu, the ones that we are
used to you in liner analysis.
And we want to use this stress
strain relationship.
We assume that the area A bar
remains constant when we pull
the bar out, or when
we push it in.
This E curl here is given via
this relationship here, E
being the Young's modulis nu
being the Poisson ratio.
In tension, the bar would be
pulled out as shown here.
Notice the area, the
cross sectional
area, remains constant.
And the displacement is
measured as t delta.
In compression, the bar would be
pushed into, as shown here.
Notice here now t delta and the
bar has been pushed in as
shown by the blue outline.
If we now apply this stress
strain law, to the problem and
develop a relationship between
the force required here to
pull the bar out or push
it in, by delta,
we obtain the following.
Here we have the Green-Lagrange
strain.
And of course, the right hand
side involves derivatives that
we have been discussing in
the previous lecture.
Notice t0u1,1 is nothing else
than this relationship here.
It's given by the current length
and the original length
of the bar.
Substituting into here, we get
directly this right hand side.
We also remember that we can
calculate or we have a very
clear relationship between the
Cauchy stress, which is the
force per unit area, which
we are interested
in calculating here.
And the second, Piola-Kirchhoff
stress, this
is the inverse of the
deformation gradient.
We substitute for here, the
Cauchy stress of course being
simply the force divided by
A bar, the inverse of the
deformation gradient
being given by this
relationship here.
And therefore we can evaluate
the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress in of the externally
applied force, the physical
force, divided by the constant
area, cross-sectional area, A
bar, and the original length
and the current length.
We therefore have now the
Green-Lagrange strain and the
second Piola-Kirchhoff stress,
in terms of current lengths
and original lengths
and force applied--
and of course the cross section
area goes in there.
Substituting these relationship
and that
relationship into our stress
strain relationship of the
previous view graph and using
this fact here, we directly
obtain this red curve in the--
which gives us the force
applied to the bar as a
function of the displacements
at the end of the bar.
Now notice that this is
a nonlinear curve--
the expression is actually
given here--
and that it is quite
unrealistic, certainly in this
region here.
It's not a realistic material
description for large strains.
You see here at this point, we
have a 0 force to be applied
when the displacement, the end
of the displacement, is minus
the original lengths
off the bar.
Quite unrealistic, of course.
And therefore, we recognize
that really this use of a
constant E and nu, going in
here, constant Young's modulus
and Poisson's ratio,
going in here.
It's really not a proper or
realistic way to proceed for
large strains.
The usual isotopical and also
orthotopic material
relationships, meeting constant
E, nu, Ea, et cetera,
the way I just showed it on a
few previous view graphs are
really almost exclusively
employed in large
displacement, large rotation,
but small strain analysis.
We should now recall one very
important namely that the
components of the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor,
and of the Green-Lagrange strain
tensor are invariant
very under a rigid body motion
of the material.
And this is most important
because we use this fact to
apply material descriptions that
are applicable to small
strain analysis directly also
to large displacement, large
rotation analysis.
You see, E nu, Ea are material
constant that applicable to
small strain analysis.
And we can directly them some
also in large displacement,
large quotation analysis,
but small strain
analysis using this fact.
And this means--
another way of saying it is
that the actual straining
increases only the components
of the Green-Lagrange strain
tensor through the material
relationships.
Let's look at this
equation here.
We have here the nodal point
force vector being equal to
the stress strain--
the strain displacement matrix
times a stress vector, the
second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress vector.
Now this vector is invariant
under rigid body rotation.
And of course, this vector
is calculated using the
constitutive relation.
This strain displacement
matrix takes
into account the rotation.
Let's look at this fact
a little bit closer.
Here we have pictorially an
element, a four-node element
say, that originally is in this
configuration, the black
configuration, and we are
pulling it out and sharing it.
If this length here is 1
originally, and that length
here is 1 originally, then this
distance here corresponds
to the Green-Lagrange strain in
the 1:1 direction, in the
one direction.
In other words, it's equal
to 1 0 epsilon 1 1.
Similar, this distance here is
equal to 1 0 epsilon 2 2, and
the total sharing is equal
to the sum of these two
components here.
This is the deformation that
brings the element, say, from
the original configuration
to state 1.
Now, going from state 1 to state
2, we rotate the element
rigidly, as shown here.
Then we know that this distance
here is still 1 0
epsilon 1 1.
Same as what we have had here.
This distance here is the same
as what we have seen here.
And the total sharing is still
the same as what the total
sharing was here.
Notice the Green-Lagrange
strain components
corresponding to the stationary
coordinate axes.
1 and 2 have not changed.
Because here this 1 and that 2
refer still too the stationary
coordinate frame.
On this view graph, we summarize
this information
once more for small strains,
we have of course this
relationship here, which means
that these strain components
are much smaller than 1.
And we can directly say that
the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress in configuration 1 is
given by the Green-Lagrange
strains in configuration 1.
Notice the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress is
approximately equal to the
Cauchy stress in state 1.
Now since state 2 is reached by
just a rigid body motion,
we find that this holds, as I
already pointed out on the
earlier view graph.
We also find that this holds.
And of course, the Cauchy
stresses in state 2 are
obtained by a rotation of the
Cauchy stresses in state 1.
But the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stresses and Green-Lagrange
strains, the components of
these two tensors are
invariant under the
rigid body motion.
And that means that we can
directly apply material
relationships that are
applicable for small strains
and infinitesimal
displacements.
Those that we are, say, already
familiar with from an
MNO analysis.
We can directly apply these to
large displacement, large
rotation, but small strain
analysis, by simply using
Green-Lagrange strains instead
of engineering strain
components, and second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses
instead of the engineering
stress components.
Applications are really all
large displacement, large
rotation, small strain
analyses of
beams, plates, and shells.
We can use for this analysis
frequently simply the 2D and
3D elements that we
discussed earlier.
But we may want to use beam and
shell elements, and those
we will discuss in
later lectures.
We also have a very large
application area here, namely,
the linearized buckling analysis
of structures.
We have already performed the
analysis of shells, or shown
how we analyze shelves
and beams
using continuum elements.
You might recall it from
the earlier lectures.
Here you have just schematically
how we would
model say a frame using
plain stress elements.
And here you should see
schematically how we are
modeling using axisymmetric
continuum elements and
axisymmetric shell.
Here we use 3D elements to
model a general shell.
But as I pointed out, we will
talk in later lectures about
actual beam and shell elements
that are frequently much more
effective in the analysis of
beam and shell structures.
This completes the first large
item that I wanted to talk to
you about, namely, the use of
constant material moduli, E,
nu, Ea, Eb, et cetera in large
displacement, large rotation
analysis, but small
strain analysis.
We found that the applicability
of constant
material moduli to large strain
analysis is really very
questionable.
For large strain analysis, we
use frequently a hyperelastic
material model.
And that is very widely used to
analyze rubber materials.
Here we have the relationship
that is basic to this
description.
We have the Piola-Kirchhoff
stress, given in terms of the
partial of the strain energy
density function, W, this
respect to the Green-Lagrange
strains.
So we get one component here,
by taking this t0W and
differentiating it with respect
to the corresponding
component of the Green-Lagrange
strain.
And of course this right
hand side gives
us this tensor t0Cijrs.
Incrementally, then, we have
an increment in the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress is given
by this stress strain
law here, involving a tangent
material description and an
increment, a differential
increment, in the
Green-Lagrange strain.
This 0Cijrs is nothing else
but the second partial
derivative of W with respect to
these Green-Lagrange strain
components.
W is a strain energy density
function per
unit original volume.
And of course that has to be
defined for the particular
material that you're looking
at and will involve certain
material constants.
For rubber, we generally use
this kind of description here,
where W is a function of I1,
I2, I3, and the Is are the
invariants of the Cauchy-Green
deformation tensor.
We discuss the Cauchy-Green
deformation tensor in an
earlier lecture.
Of course, it's given in terms
of the deformation gradient.
So I1 is equal to this.
I2 is equal to this relationship
here on
the right hand side.
And I3 is simply the
determinant of the
Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor.
For example, one material law
that is quite widely used is
the Mooney-Rivlin material
law, where two
constants enter here.
And of course, we have
here I1 and 12.
These are material constants
that have to be determined
depending on what rubber
you're dealing with.
And the incompressibility
constraint is imposed onto the
formulation by having
I3 equal to 1.
Of course, rubber is an
incompressible material, at
least almost an incompressible
material, and is modeled as an
incompressible material.
And so we want to have
I3 equal to 1.
In general, if you deal with
incompressible materials, it
is effective to not use the
displacement-based finite
element formulations the way
I've been discussing it in the
previous lectures, but to amend
that formulation, you
should really extend that
formulation to have an
effective formulation
to deal with
incompressibility in the analysis.
Except for the plane stress
case, we can directly use what
we discussed earlier.
The formation for
incompressibility, or for
analysis of incompressible
materials, such formulations
of course are very valuable
but the discussion of such
formulations really deserves
another lecture.
Well, we like to now show how
this material law is used in
the plane stress case.
There we can directly employ
the formulation that we
discussed in the earlier
lectures.
Time 0, for example, we would
have a piece of material as
shown here.
At time t, this piece of
material has deformed, as
shown here.
Notice plane stress of course
means stress is
0 through the thickness.
For this two-dimensional
problem, the Cauchy-Green
deformation tensor
is as shown here.
0 components here.
And we imposed the
incompressibility of the
material by simply setting the
determinant of this matrix
equal to 1.
And this gives us then a
constraint on T0C33.
Basically, we are saying
physically that we constrain
the material to shrink into this
33 direction such that
for the applied stresses in the
plane of the material, the
material acts as
incompressible.
And that's what's being done
here mathematically.
We can now evaluate with this
constraint I1 and I2.
Here you see the expressions.
And if we have I1 and I2, we
can go back to the material
law, substitute and directly
octane obtain our second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses, in
terms of the Cauchy-Green
deformation tensor components.
And of course, we also have
a relationship between the
Cauchy-Green deformation tensor
components and the
Green-Lagrange strain
components.
Those we use.
That relationship we use, and
that actually brings into it
this relationship here.
And if you performed then the
differentiation, the final
result is shown on
this view graph.
This is the stress strain
relationship that gives the
total stresses in terms
of the Cij components.
You similarly proceed to also
calculate the tangent
relationship, the tangent
stress strain law.
As I pointed out earlier, you
need to now take second
derivatives of W with respect
to the Green-Lagrange strain
components.
And if you also use the
relationships between the
Green-Lagrange strain components
and the components
of the Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor, you
directly arrive at
this expression.
And of course now, you would
have to substitute as we did
earlier for calculating the
total stress strain law, in
other words, the stress strain
giving us a total stress as a
function of the total
deformations.
You proceed in the same way, and
obtain the tangent stress
strain law.
Let us now look at an example.
In this example, we are
considering the analysis of a
tensile test specimen.
The specimen is shown here.
All dimensions are given
in millimeters.
The thickness of the specimen
is one millimeter, and the
Mooney-Rivlin constants
are given here.
We need to model only one
quarter of the specimen
because of symmetry
conditions.
And in the analysis, we used
14 eight-node elements to
represent this quarter
of the specimen.
Notice that on the right hand
side, we constrained all
material particles to move
together and only move to the
right, as shown by delta here.
This represents 1/2 the gauge
length of the specimen, and
one is particularly interested
in seeing the deformations in
that gauge length.
This view graph now shows
the calculated response.
The applied node
is given here.
The extension is given here.
This is the gauge response.
And that gives us--
this curve gives us the
total response.
Of course, quite nonlinear,
because the material is a
nonlinear elastic material.
The deformed mesh is shown on
the next view graph here.
At the force 4 Newton, we
have this deformed mesh
here shown in red.
And notice here, we have the
undeformed mesh in dashed
black line.
Notice that the displacements
are large, and the strains
certainly are very large
in this problem.
Finally I would like to share
with you some analysis results
that we obtained in the analysis
of a rubber sheet
with a hole.
And these analysis results are
shown on the slides, so let me
walk over here so that we can
share that information.
Here, we show the
rubber sheet.
It's a square sheet, 20 inch
by 20 inch, that contains a
hole of diameter 6-inch.
Notice the sheet is subjected
to a force on the left hand
side, the distributed
pressure, uniformly
distributed pressure on the
left hand side and on the
right hand side.
The mass density is given over
here also, and the thickness
off the sheet is given
here as well.
We will use the mass density
later on when we perform also
or look at the results of
a dynamic analysis.
The next slide now shows the
finite element mesh that we
used to model one quarter
of the sheet.
We only needed to model one
quarter because of symmetry
conditions.
Notice we used four-node
elements in this mesh, and
that the distributive pressure
on this right hand side is
modeled by concentrated
loads at these nodes.
The next slide shows
now the solution
results that we obtained.
Notice down here, we have a
little key for the points that
we want to look at.
Here is point B. Here is point
A. And here is point C. The
graphs here shows the
displacements at point B, at
point A, and point C. In each
case, the W displacement,
which at point B is into this
direction, at point A is into
this direction, but at
point C is downwards.
Notice the very large
displacements, W here, going
up to 10, 11 inches for
the load applied.
Remember the sheet is a square
sheet of 20 inches, so we have
very large deformations here.
We are computing our solution
results obtained in the total
Lagrangian formulation, with the
hyperelastic Mooney-Rivlin
material law, with the results
obtained by Iding.
In fact, there is almost no
difference between our
results, and the results of
Iding, so that we could not
plot the difference.
And these curves here
refer to our results
and the Iding results.
The next slide now shows the
deformations that the sheet
has undergone at maximum load.
Here is the original
configuration of the sheet,
the initial configuration.
And here, we show the deformed
configuration of the sheet.
Notice that the sheet has
undergone very large
displacements and very large
strains, particularly of
course here in the region
of the hole.
The final slide then shows the
dynamic response that the
sheet undergoes when we subject
the sheet to a step
loading, where the static
loading was applied before.
Notice the step loading is
applied over 10 delta-t where
delta-a is 0.0015 seconds.
It goes up linearly to 75 pounds
per square inch, and
then it stays constant.
Once again, we're looking at the
displacements at point B,
point A, W displacements here,
and at point C downward
displacement, again denoted
as W. Here you see
the solution response.
Point B, point A, and point C.
In this particular analysis,
we used first the Newmark method
with data equal to 1/2
and alpha equal to 1/4.
In fact, that is nothing else
than the trapezoidal rule,
which we discussed in
an earlier lecture.
We also performed the analysis
once with the Wilson theta
method, theta being 1.4.
This method we did not discuss
in the earlier lecture, but it
is described in the textbook.
Notice that the results obtained
using the Newmark
method and the Wilson theta
method are really very close
to each other.
It's also interesting to see the
static response that the
sheet undergoes for this load
level at the points A, B, and
C, and that is given by these
horizontal lines.
Once again, you have here a
large displacement and very
large strain problem.
This brings me to the end of
what I wanted to discuss with
you in this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.